may is mental health awareness month and
we're having important conversations
about mental health every monday this
month one in five americans will
experience mental illness in any given
year
and one in five children struggle with
mental health but finding and paying for
mental health care can be challenging
and overwhelming research shows that
only 46 percent of adults with mental
illness received health care for it
jamie howard is a senior clinical
psychologist from the child mind
institute jamie good morning how you
doing good morning good thank you um so
there are many different types of mental
health care um where what are the
different types and then where do you
start right okay so the term therapist
can be confusing because it refers to a
wide array of professionals so one is a
licensed clinical social worker that you
might hear of this is someone who has a
master's degree with specialization in
providing therapy then there's a
clinical psychologist like myself
and the letters you might see are phd or
psyd and we specialize in providing
therapy as well we also do research and
provide testing and then there's
psychiatrists and they have mds they go
to medical school and they usually tend
to focus on prescribing medicine so
there's all of these different
professionals who can provide mental
health care one of the most important
things you want to look for is what we
call evidence-based
mental health care so that means that
there's research to support the various
elements of the therapy that your
provider is administering and one of the
most important things is to remember
regardless of what type of mental health
care provider you have you want them to
be licensed and credentialed okay so so
how do you know as a parent when it's
time to seek out professional help right
so there's a few things we want to keep
in mind when you're monitoring your
child's mood or behavior you want to
think about the duration how long has
this been going on for if it's been up
to a month or so that's when we start to
think that treatment might be indicated
and you should at least get an
evaluation
you also want to consider the intensity
so is this symptom so for example you
have a very irritable teenager is this
like any other teenager are they just
kind of difficult right now or is this
more significant you can sort of get a
sense by talking to other parents or
teachers pediatrician to get a sense of
that then you also want to look at the
frequency if it's happening most days
the mood or behavior problem that you're
noticing then it's also a good
indication to get treatment some people
may make a call and say all right it's
time whether it's for myself as an adult
or my family members my kids but then
they can be booked up for months at a
time right um so what do you do in that
situation so one thing we like to
recommend is that you start with either
your general practitioner or your
pediatrician because sometimes they can
actually treat the medical issues
underlying a psychological condition and
then if not they also usually have
really good community resources to refer
you to they might sort of have their
finger on the pulse of who's available
and where's a good place to go the other
thing to keep in mind is telehealth
so
it's sort of the silver lining of the
pandemic in so many ways because it's
reduced a lot of barriers to care for
families for adults and children alike
so i still do a lot of telehealth in my
practice even though we're able to meet
in person people just tend to prefer it
because you don't have to deal with
parking and transportation it just cuts
down on a lot of hassle jamie you're the
best thank you so much thank you i
appreciate you